final one buying a hint I figure okay
okay okay so that's zero points for me
baby I'm gonna argue no no no no no
here's why I didn't I didn't realize
this but you can replace Reese's tits to
be uncensored are you serious yeah yeah
yeah I didn't know I didn't know what
that was until I opened it up those are
just nipples they came with
interchangeable nipples we're gonna find
that out after yeah so why think they're
attached to the hell yeah oh my god I
mean I would like to argue that you
buying the dakimakura already counts
like I think but that wasn't a figure
but III think that uncensored nipples
counts as a hentai figure because we
can't know but but is it though cuz it's
highschool DxD it's not technically hand
tie I mean if there's tits out though is
it a hentai figure I mean I would like
to argue that if it's something we can't
show yes it's something we can't show in
this podcast which I have to look you've
gone point okay